peut fermer dix quinze jours et
peut-être on se dit heureux d'être dans
quinze jours ça va on va on va être bien
pour les fêtes c'est en tout cas la
volonté du président de la république et
du gouvernement ce que ça prend il ya
personne qui prend plaisir à fermer les
boîtes de nuit et moi j'ai encore eu des
amis hier que son dj bien sûr serveurs
dans les boîtes de nuit qui tiennent des
boîtes de nuit vont qui n'ont pas comblé
les sillons donc il ya des discussions
qui sont menées aujourd'hui est notre
objectif c'est de les rouvrir le plus
vite possible mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui si on prend d'un point de
vue statistique les contaminations sont
plus forts dans les boîtes de nuit que
dans d'autres endroits et les
statistiques elles ont été faites quand
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe dans
les boîtes de nuit on est quand même le
seul à contrôler le pass and i ter sûr
mais également l'appui d'entités les
seuls ses reflets dans les restaurants
dans les bars dans les musées ont peu
importe vous allez vous pouvez avoir une
fausse info un faux-pas sanitaire parce
que vous contrôlez pas les petites
entités ou comment vous pouvez dire ce
sont les boîtes de nuit stigmatiser les
boîtes de nuit c'est l'étude qui sera
encore de cet été de l'étude c'est déjà
si ces faits étaient donc c'était une
aventure à d'autres études volontaire
avant le pass sanitaire avant la lépi
d'identité au passé à terre et encore
hier c'était un début mais pour revenir
là dessus en mêlée même au niveau
européen si on regarde tout le monde a
fermé presque toutes ces boîtes de nuit
à cause de ça donc l'art est jeune mais
je comprends très bien votre désarroi et
moi je faisais partie des personnes qui
voulait rouvrir le plus tôt possible et
vous décidez vous mois de juin donc cet
arrêté vous dansez vous lui dont à metz
je crois pas de publicité leylaz
plusieurs ont d'ailleurs on a eu des
très très belles belles boîtes de nuit
et
c'est dommage parce que même pour le
jeune homme aime pollono patron boîte
leur objectif c'est quand même de faire
vivre la nuit de donner 7 mai pour
priorisation françaises voisines attisé
la boîte de nuit alors que vous avez par
exemple les bars vous avez les
restaurants les restaurants festif qui
eux ne contrôle pas en fait le pas
sanitaire enfin il le contrôle
compétentes identité donc et encore plus
de possibilités clusters et là ce qui se
passe quand on ferme une boîte de nuit
moi j'ai déjà des personnes qui m'a qui
m'interpelle il ya déjà des soirées
clandestines qui se met en place et vous
avez aussi les gens qui font des soirées
chez eux donc en gros on va fermer les
boîtes de nuit vous avez un contrôle
pour envoyer les gens chez eux ou dans
des fêtes clandestines en leur disant
ego les gains fait des clusters c'est
pas logique il n'y a aucune logique en
fait
ces anciens il a entièrement raison
monsieur cédric merci c'est un vrai
problème je sais pas ce qu'en bas de
chez lui plus en plus
et donc si vous voulez
donc je disais j'ai justement un bel
appartement en bas de chez moi et je
peux vous dire qu'ils font des fêtes
régulièrement tous les soirs et c'est un
bordel ils en ont rien à [ __ ] je sais
et on sait très bien qu'ils avaient leur
organise des fêtes mal dessiné c'est bon
maintenant des chansons je sais que vous
êtes le plus concerné parce que les
autres non mais je trouve que cette
décision elle est adaptée à une
humiliante inutile millan tu vois la
plus humiliante parce que maintenant
c'est officiel le gouvernement il a
établi une hiérarchie entre les lieux
qu'ils jugent utiles et les lieux qui
selon eux ne servent à rien et je trouve
que c'est vraiment un manque de respect
pour les patrons boîte de nuit c'est
leur dire si on lit entre les lignes on
m'a vous on s'en fout la société peut
tourner sans vous il n'ya pas d'économie
que c'est pas vrai et inutile parce que
les gens vont continuer de s'entasser
dehors dans les restaurants dans les
soirées clandestines dans les boîtes de
nuit clandestine donc soit la situation
elle est catastrophique et on reconfirme
mais faut arrêter de prendre des mesures
tièdes comme ça c'est ça sert à rien
passé juste en fait c'est juste une
décision politique on a l'impression
qu'il ya les élections dans pas
longtemps donc si on prend pas de
décision on va se faire taper sur les
doigts si on prend des décisions trop
forte on va se passer parce qu'ils
veulent les rouvrir pour les fêtes
mais voilà nos pas être faites pas pour
les fêtes de noël ce que nous allons le
jour de noël dans la petite frayeur
alors vous avez raison sur un point
c'est que les fêtes clandestines quoi
qu'il arrive il faut qu'on puisse
dénoncer aussi se fait mais d'aller
danser avec le destiner ne pas respecter
les mails et les règles de bases
militaires on est d'accord sur le fait
que vous avez très bien joué le rôle de
contrôle et j'ai vu beaucoup de
personnes se faire refouler encore
vendredi soir quand j'étais visité
certains de mes amis en boîte donné donc
voilà je peux témoigner
mais il faut bien qu'on espèce de vie à
côté mais ça permet de renommer ses
terrains équivalent à voir ce que c'est
des chansons les on est d'accord là
dessus maintenant c'est les chiffres qui
sortent iribus fois plus de
contaminations possibles quand on est
dans une boîte très intéressés à ce que
vous le savez si bris mais aussi à ce
que vous le savez aussi bien que nous
c'est que les personnes quant à son état
d'ébriété el fan l'a beaucoup moins la
commission des personnes quand ce sont
des personnes qui ont un pass sanitaires
qui sont ici pas de légumes et les
entités donc alors vous allez parler
d'ébriété
mais il y avait une solution plutôt que
de donner des subventions pour les
bonnes données qu'ils vont faire mais
pourquoi vous avez pape a demandé
l'autotest juste avant de rejoindre la
boîte s'est déréglé qu'on a de la
réflexion du président l'a
replacé dans les scénarios exxon
regarder ailleurs françois hollande a
été président tu peux aussi mais c'est
fou hein c'est ce qui est fou c'est
qu'on aurait pu y penser sans fermer
bahonnar l'anticipation presque autant
marié que lui sauf que ben bernanke en
temps des décisions aussi dans la
rapidité je peux comprendre le désarroi
et je le dis honnêtement je comprends
votre désarroi après là ils vont
protéger au maximum et je rappelle que
au delà des deux boîtes de nuit il ya
beaucoup de choses qui s'annulent de
même il ya beaucoup d'évènements compte
annuler ça concerne les traiteurs sa
content et dj magicien ça concerne
énormément de monde
tous les mecs du danseur les cours de
danse et on en a rien là aussi au club
en faisant galère de danse donc ça c'est
pareil même en dehors des bois de
l'événementiel prend très cher ces
derniers temps sur pascal beaucoup
d'annulations c'est magique et paito par
les entreprises par les communes